um for you uh obviously so you want to
ball to your 50 but what are other
things you're trying to like do to kind
of just expand like the Empire yeah
obviously you got merch you got stuff
you're selling but like give me kind of
the breakdown on mobile hooper.com
Global hooper.com yeah so uh when you
talk about expansion I'm actually trying
to produce a movie of my life story
where I play myself so I've been working
out on that for a couple of years you
better get that film soon because you're
still listening to strike don't help you
know what I'm saying the strikes [__]
everything it's not helping but uh
except for 2B yeah they're two maybe I
think I think you can still get a 2B
movie off and the SAG won't be mad I'm
inside yeah I don't know so if you're in
Sag you should not you're on strike you
are on strike I heard they're like gay
it's like gang [__] like you cannot
cross the strike yeah it's real it's
real it's real so um so now we respect
and all that but you know trying to put
more of a foot into the acting world I
don't think I'd ever stop my YouTube
channel just because like you've seen
even A-list Stars a influencers also and
I've seen even like big YouTubers go
mainstream or do something mainstream
and then have to come back to YouTube
yeah
actually a lot then the algorithm is all
messed up it's not like it was before so
I don't I don't ever want to let up off
the gas personally I just think man
controlling your own narrative is a
beautiful thing you're Your Own Boss
over there if people don't want to give
you work elsewhere you still got that
and it's it is TV like the number one
used app on my TV is YouTube yeah I mean
it's number one streaming app in the
world in fact I'm I don't care about
like I don't watch Netflix unless like
some show drops like I just watched
quarterbacks okay but I'm always on
YouTube my kids are on YouTube yeah me
too me too if I'm not if I'm not
watching Netflix it's YouTube So yeah so
you're essentially you're like you want
to just kind of dip your toe into like
producing like original content or being
a part of like movies on a bigger scale
yeah as well as still keeping your foot
on the mainly acting a little bit of
producing yeah for sure but also for me
it's funny as long as I've gone you know
start my YouTube channel 09 the weakness
of my brand has actually always been
infrastructure I didn't upload enough
and now as we get further into it people
upload way way more yeah I was gonna say
how often are you uh are you dropping
content now Orion go four to six times a
month but I've always had I've always
been like kind of like Mr Beast where
you take a lot of time for video
treating like a TV show where
everything's perfect good sound amazing
concept you're aiming to break the
internet but we sometimes we only get
one or two of a month right well that
was good yeah don't get me wrong it's
good like I think there's a more a
better from a business standpoint what's
your most viewed YouTube video
uh 83 mil views but what what what what
were you doing oh I went to Laguna Beach
and I played a trash talker it was
actually the first my first Trash talker
video I came up with that that turn the
trash talk yeah uh dude was just talking
crazy I was I had been up there for like
three hours of playing at the Laguna
courts you know in Laguna Beach and um
this dude came up and he was just
he's trying to discredit Everything I
did and then he knew exactly who you
were
I don't think he did so he didn't know I
don't think so maybe maybe but I don't
think so so then he was like giving the
dude a hard time it was guarding Me
Maybe he knew them but he kept he kept
saying after every bucket I would get
like man you gotta do this do this and
he's like all you got to do is watch his
hips and so uh he's like man I got next
and I was like I said something like
well maybe we should get a ones in he's
like yeah let's get the ones in so I was
like all right cool so we finished that
game and I was like all right man ain't
trying to do it and then we matched up
one on one
he was a little bit heavy set though
so Midway through the gang a little
winded did a move went between his legs
snatched it I didn't even touch him he
smacked he like smack hit the pavement
right then like two plays later I did
somewhere up faked between my legs
between his legs snatch it he broke his
shoulder he like he like reached he
threw his shoulder out of the socket
so the game did that's why I got eight
three mil views the game didn't even end
we couldn't have wrote a better script
holy [__] yeah so so when we edit it we
go to the edit we told the story of how
the game happened because that was one
of my critiques that we don't play good
enough competition right it's like I
play anybody in the street Streetball so
we told a story of why that game went
down but then we realized oh like we
gotta do this every video you got to
tell us yeah tell the story to go the
thumb was a zoom in to the ankle breaker
so it kind of that laid the it that
paved the way for how I need to do
videos and even the title I had money in
the title yeah I played a game for 100
bucks or whatever it's trash talker wow
yeah 83 million yeah I think that was
2016. that's fully uh monetized oh for
sure 2016. that's for sure yeah yeah a
lifetime analytics on there nice is it
safe to say you've surpassed your ann1
pay as a YouTuber by like a 10 or 30
times by now yeah yeah I was gonna say
somewhere around 20 times I mean not to
get in your pockets but back in the day
like what was what was the pay decent
like like if you guys are hitting the
road it was decent yeah I don't mind I
think my first contract ever with anyone
18 years old was like 70k 60 70k not bad
for an 18 year old kid professionally
playing Hoops back then before inflation
hit the [__] not bad yeah I wasn't
bad but then as we went it went big so
we did you know
multi multi-year six-figure deals like
by the time I left I think I signed a
250k a year yeah 250k or something last
year but then we would make money
outside of a12 so you could go do that
then you could go do oh I'm gonna go do
an appearance or I'm gonna go play in a
game in China or Africa or yeah yeah so
I think my last year
I think one of the years I made 800k or
something like that and so that was cool
but just hooping just hooping just well
I think we made millions of dollars the
whole run the whole run of course but as
you're saying like for a single year for
a single year I was like awesome I
thought I was rich I thought my money
would never run out was was uh
everyone's pay scale is different do you
know or like because obviously there's
bigger names smaller names like because
I I think when I think I want to think
of you I think a hot sauce I think uh I
think Escalade uh I think of uh half and
half amazing I think of uh who else and
you're probably different you watched it
you know the casuals they say like me
hot sauce and then it's either like
Skipper Escalade yeah maybe AO
yeah AO was dope yeah yeah yeah damn
that's crazy yeah damn yeah but no it's
based on marketability and skill so like
what you bring to the table on the court
played a role but then obviously your
marketability so I'm sure like Apostles
had the biggest deal I was like skip was
already in the NBA but like you know I'm
sure hot sauce had the biggest
households AO Maine